Russell Banks donc avec vous mine on a
décidé de s'arrêter sur sur l'auteur de
temps qu'en plus il était à Paris et
c'est donc un grand plaisir de le
recevoir
et donc American Darling en fait c'est
une sorte de vaste fresque un roman en
fait d'une génération celle des années
60 aux États-Unis à travers le parcours
d'une femme nommée Anna donc Anna
Musgrave c'est une jeune femme au début
du livre c'est une vieille femme mais
elle revient sur son parcours elle est
issue de la bourgeoisie qui s'est
engagée dans les années 60 dans les
mouvements contestataires à la flirté un
moment avec le terrorisme et ensuite
elle s'est exilée au Liberia d'où elle
est revenue ensuite on y laissant là-bas
son mari et ses enfants qui étaient
noirs et qui appartenait d'ailleurs
administration politique du Liberia
alors en fait c'est un livre d'abord une
quête identitaire donc c'est une femme
qui se charge qui cherche politiquement
qui cherche même sexuellement qui
cherchent même par rapport à sa famille
c'est aussi un livre donc sur l'héritage
des mouvements contestataires c'est un
livre qui entre elle histoire collective
histoire individuelle constamment et
c'est également un livre
c'est noté un moment dans le roman sur
le basculement du nerf à une autre et
dont le 11 septembre finalement une date
charnière
donc voilà bon sur l'identité
Anna qui est donc cette contestataire
dans les années 60-70 et le flirte avec
le terrorisme urbain il y a cette
tentation là dans ces milieux là au
tournant de ces années là donc un jour
elle décide de partir au Liberia parce
que elle est recherchée par le FBI et le
jour elle décide de partir et elle
explique de cette manière là nous sommes
restés un long moment à six à sa face
sans rien dire pendant que j'essayais de
laisser mon nom recouvrir mon corps et
mon esprit mais il ne m'allait pas tout
à fait quand je m'en enveloppais il me
serrait et me tirait par endroit il
était devenu trop étroit comme s'il
avait été taillé pour le corps et
l'esprit d'une autre d'une femme que je
ne connaissais pratiquement pas je
n'étais plus là anamus grave entrer dans
la clandestinité en 1970 disparu du
monde de ses parents de sa ville et de
son université de ces lieux où elle
avait jadis joué un rôle central ou du
moins un rôle connu et reconnu et si je
ne pouvais pas revenir à l'ancienne Anna
que j'avais abandonné je ne pouvais pas
davantage effectuer un grand bon en
avant et devenir la nouvelle Anna qui
s'en était bien tiré dieu merci et qui
peut raconter ses histoires bien des
années plus tard voilà bien la question
de l'identité Russell bouse et est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord sur sur la quête
identité et sur un thème qui traverse
toute votre œuvre qui est celui de la
filiation le rapport aux parents et le
rapport au delà de la filiation le
rapport à son milieu à son origine
effectivement je pense
que c'est un véritable moteur central
qui nous fait avancer mais je ne
souhaitais pas que ce soit la seule
force motrice la dynamique familiale la
psychologie du personnage je pense que
personne ne peut inventer complètement
sa vie
il y a d'autres facteurs
et ce que j'essaie de faire avec ce
personnage
de mettre en jeu l'ensemble des
motivations donc la filiation oui le
l'espace et le lieu historique les
années
60-70 facteurs
il y a également d'autres facteurs les
gens avec qui il est en contact ses
collègues les autres étudiants ce sont
des éléments qui sont bien tressés
ensemble en tout cas je l'espère il ne
s'agit pas de prendre une psychologie
familiale réductionniste je ne veux pas
le nier mais ce n'est qu'une partie de
du phénomène
quand on regarde maintenant à travers le
prisme du 11 septembre quand on examine
cette période-là nous avons tendance à
réduire un petit peu le comportement de
ce qui est ma génération après tout à
une psychologie peut-être quelque peu
réduite
on y trouve certainement des influences
dans des cas particuliers mais il y a
d'autres facteurs que j'ai essayé de
faire intervenir dans le roman
l'histoire le moment dans l'histoire
là vous pouvez y avoir un changement
dans les institutions la politique
également les idéologies qui étaient à
l'époque vous êtes un observateur de
votre temps et vous êtes un militant
pour l'abolition de la peine de mort
vous comprendrez à la fin de l'émission
parce que je rappelle systématiquement
que la peine de mort n'a pas été abolie
aux États-Unis à la fin de cette
émission mais par rapport à ce que vous
venez de dire il y a une seconde entre
Lyon 11 septembre et le drame de la
Nouvelle-Orléans et est-ce que ça révèle
les mêmes travers de l'Amérique ou les
mêmes souffrances que peut-on durer
l'Amérique est-ce que est-ce que ça sont
deux extrêmes ou de violence qui sont
faites à l'Amérique et qui diraient
quelque chose de de cette raison
juste après l'ouragan je n'étais plus
aux États-Unis
je suis allé à Berlin et quelques heures
avant donc j'ai suivi les choses à
travers la chaîne cnen et puis ensuite
je suis arrivé en France c'était très
intéressant pour moi de vivre cela parce
que pendant 48 heures il y a eu de
vraies informations parce qu'il n'y
avait pas de journaliste sur place
pendant les 48 heures
comme nous avions des journalistes
embarqués en Irak il y avait donc des
reporters qui étaient là devant les
militaires la police des illusions
gouvernementales avec des équipes des
caméras pendant 48 heures on pouvait
voir c'est comme si on avait soulevé un
couvercle tout d'un coup et on voyait
bon ça a duré 48 heures c'était une
fenêtre très courte pendant laquelle on
a vu la réalité secrète de la guerre
américaine
on a vu les problèmes de race de classe
ces liens très très étroits mais nous
l'avons vu pendant 48 heures et ensuite
les institutions
et les organisateurs des informations
Atlanta
ont commencé à donner un éclairage un
peu plus soft peut-être
pour rendre les choses un peu plus soft
pour les téléspectateurs je pense que
les 40 premières les premières 48 heures
étaient tout à fait révélatrices
vous savez en février est-ce que en
février prochain lors du Mardi Gras nous
pouvons nous rappeler nous pouvons nous
rappeler ces images c'est une autre
question mais il y a eu
cette petite fenêtre et c'était quelque
part un petit peu rafraîchissant après
les quatre dernières années
moi ce que je voulais vous poser comme
question c'est que c'est vrai que vous
êtes connu comme le romancier qui a le
plus dénoncé finalement le rêve
américain sous toutes ses formes et vous
avez déclaré que ce livre donc American
Darling c'était les livres le plus
pessimiste que vous aviez jamais écrit
et que ça reflètait en fait votre vision
actuelle de la mairie j'aimerais que
vous développer cette idée
et peut-être un fantasme américain cela
nous ramène à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure
concernant ce couvercle
très lourd qui a été soulevé un petit
peu ce qui nous a permis de voir pendant
un bref moment la réalité mais ce
fantasme américain
ce qui encourage leur américain c'est
cette idée cette idéale d'une société
intégrée sur le plan racial et au cours
des quatre dernières années surtout mais
depuis qu'il y a une administration
bouche en fait les divisions entre les
races et entre les classes sociales
sont devenus de plus en plus rigide de
plus en plus
douloureuse de plus en plus large donc
ce fantasme doit s'effondrer doit
s'écrouler
il faut davantage d'énergie pour garder
ce rêve américain oui effectivement je
suis pessimiste mais ça n'est pas un
pessimiste qui
ne se passe pas seulement sur la
différence entre le rêve et la réalité
américain cela c'est quelque chose qui
est là depuis longtemps mon pessimisme
se fonde surtout sur ce que je perçois
comme la mise en place progressive
d'un état
que je ne peux que décrire comme une
plutôt classique
au cours des cartes dernières années la
progression dans ce sens était de plus
en plus rapide
extraordinairement rapide c'est assez
beaucoup institutionnalisé et je ne vois
pas comment cela pourrait changer d'ici
la fin de ma vie
donc vous voyez ça rend la perspective
un peu sombre pour moi en fait vous
poser
American Darling vous posez la question
de l'action c'est quoi et Anna cette
ancienne activiste
en Afrique se pose la question de
l'action parce qu'elle épouse un
ministre libérien qu'elle a des enfants
avec lui et qu'ils vivent et qu'à
quelques mètres de là où il vivent il y
a la misère il y a la mort quotidienne
et
l'écrit ceci dans le récit de sa vie
mais même dans ce petit cercle de
voisins d'amis et de parents qui tousse
avait désespérément besoin d'aide je
n'ai été d'aucun secours durable je ne
saurais dire même aujourd'hui si la
pauvreté à l'intérieur de ce cercle
était réellement impossible à éliminer
comme les tesselles du reste du pays
mais elle m'apparaissait alors comme un
ta figée et sans espoir irrémédiable
aussi permanent et inaltérable qu'un
code génétique je crois que ça ça résume
bien ce que ce que vous ce que vous
venez de dire j'ai une dernière question
à vous poser dans dans le magazine
trimestriel transfuges magazine de la
littérature étrangère quand Clémence
boulot vous pose question de vos
références en littérature vous citez
Joyce Carole vous citez Tony Morrison
parce que dites-vous ce sont des gens
qui sont restés proches de leur milieu
d'origine c'est-à-dire que dans toute
leur littérature il y a cette référence
au milieu du régime vous vous êtes né
dans un milieu modeste et vous êtes le
seul à avoir réussi à passer le cap des
études en revanche le seul qui qui ne
trouve pas grâce à vos yeux enfin ceux
qui ne trouvent pas grâce à vos yeux
c'est Hemingway parce que vous dites que
vous dites que lui c'est perdu parce
qu'il a il a oublié d'où il venait et
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui alors que vous
avez réussi que vous êtes connu y
compris aux États-Unis que le système ne
vous a pas mangé aux États-Unis est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes toujours dans
cette dans ce besoin de l'origine
oui je pense
c'est relativement important pour moi
je me sens un petit peu comme une plante
je ne peux pas me déraciner je ne peux
pas me couper de mes racines sinon je ne
pourrai pas vivre je m'étonnerai je ne
pourrais que mourir en tant qu'être
humain
en partie c'est juste une question de
fidélité par rapport aux gens que j'ai
connu et que j'ai aimé dans mon enfance
dans mon adolescence c'est la mémoire le
souvenir de leur vie de leur lutte et je
ne ferai pas abandonner tout cela mais
en partie il y a peut-être une crainte
d'un syndrome de la grosse tête si vous
voulez d'une grande célébrité c'est
quelque chose qui se passe notamment aux
Etats-Unis
parfois l'écrivain est plus important
que le livre et je ressens une certaine
angoisse à l'égard de cela et j'essaye
de me blinder contre cela donc ça n'est
pas seulement la fidélité au milieu
c'est également ma tâche à laquelle
j'essaie d'être fidèle en tant
qu'écrivain
[Musique]